We're on problem 205.
In the table above, what
is the number of green
marbles in jar R?
OK.
Let's see, they give us
a table, they have
jars P, Q, and R.
They say number of red,
is x, y, and x.
And they tell us the number
of green is y, z, and z.
And then they tell us the total
is 80, 120, and 160.
And they say, in the table
above, what is the number of
green marbles in jars?
So we need to solve for z.
So what we have here is
three variables and
we have three unknowns.
We actually have three equations
because we know that
the red plus the green is equal
to the total for any one
of the jars.
y plus z is equal to 120 and
x plus z is equal to 160.
So let's just try to solve
this equation.
So let's try to get everything--
I don't know,
what do we want to
cancel out first?
What happens if we subtract that
equation from this one?
Let me write that one over.
So that's x plus y
is equal to 80.
I just rewrote that
column down here.
Now, if we were to subtract this
from that-- let's just
well multiply it
by negative 1.
So, minus x, minus
y, minus 80.
And now let's just add them.
We get 0 plus z minus y, so we
get z minus y is equal to--
what's 160 minus 80?
Well that's just 80.
And now, this is interesting,
we have x minus y equals 80,
and z plus y is equal to 120.
So I think we're pretty close.
Let's write that.
So we could write
this equation--
I'll write it in yellow.
z plus y-- I just switched the
order-- is equal to 120.
But, in the back of my mind, I'm
like, well, all I have to
do is figure out these.
If I can figure out
these as fast as
possible, all the better.
Add these two equations.
2z plus 0 is equal to 240.
z is equal to 120.
And that's the number of
green marbles in jar R.
120.
And that is not one
of the choices.
Where did I make a mistake?
I often make a mistake
right near the end.
Let's see.
x plus z.
Let me see.
X plus y is equal to 80.
y plus z is equal to 120.
x plus z is equal to 160.
Now, I took this equation--
no, I took this one and I
multiplied it by negative
1 and put it here.
Minus x, minus y, is
equal to minus 80.
Then I added these two.
So the x's cancel out and you're
left with z minus y is
equal to 80.
And then, this equation says y
plus z is equal to 120-- oh, I
see my mistake.
You see, I made it
right at the end.
z minus y is equal to 80.
z plus y is equal to 120.
80 plus 120 is not 240.
80 plus 120 is 200.
So 2z is equal to 200.
z is equal to 100.
Boneheaded mistake.
So the answer is 100.
D.
Next question.
Question 206.
In the circle above, PQ-- let
me draw the circle above.
This is the circle above.
Let's see, in the circle
above, PQ-- OK
they then draw diameter.
Let me draw diameter as well.
Because I want to be accurate.
So that's diameter and they
labelled this as O and R.
And they say PQ-- so they have
this other line up here that
this is parallel to
the diameter.
So let me draw it up here.
Maybe it looks something
like this.
That's parallel.
And they call this point
P and this point Q.
And then they have another
line they say
is a 35 degree angle.
Let me see if I can draw that.
You have a line that goes
from here to here.
And they tell us
that this angle
right here is 35 degrees.
In the circle above, PQ is
parallel to diameter OR.
And OR has length 18.
What is the length
of minor arc PQ?
Fascinating.
So, they want to know
what this is.
So, we can figure out the
circumference of this circle.
The circumference, we
know its diameter.
It's just going to be the
diameter times pi.
So, we already know that the
circumference of the circle is
18 pi or 2 times the
radius times pi.
But same thing.
Now, in order to figure out this
arc length, what would be
useful-- and I don't know yet if
I can figure it out, is if
we could figure out this
angle right here.
If we could figure out
this angle right
here, we'd be done.
We could easily figure it out
because that angle as a
proportion of 360 would be the
same relative proportion of
the total radius.
So let's see if we can figure
out what that angle is.
Just given the information
they've given us.
This angle here's is going
to be 35 degrees.
And how did I know that?
Well, those are those are
opposite inside angles.
Let me see.
What matters is-- let me think
about it a little bit.
And this is on the circle.
Oh, well this is interesting.
We should use the information.
This is a circle.
So, what is the length
of that right there?
Well, if the diameter is 18 then
the radius is 9, right?
If that length is 9, than this
length is also going to be 9.
And if that length is 9--
oh this is interesting.
This length is 9, this
length is also 9.
That length also has to be 9.
They're both radiuses of the
circle which tells us that
this, right here, is kind
of an isosceles
triangle on its side.
It looks like that.
Where these sides are equal.
They're both equal to 9.
So, if this is a 35 degree
angle, then this, right here,
has to be a 35 degree
angle as well.
I know you can't read it.
Because the base angles of an
isosceles triangle are equal.
I could redraw it like this.
This is an interesting
problem.
So, if we know that length is
equal to that length, we know
that angle is equal
to that angle.
So, then we know that this angle
right here has also got
to be equal to 35.
This is useful because if this
angle is 35 and this angle is
35, what is this entire angle?
What is that entire angle?
Well that entire angle--
let me draw it up here.
So that's the PQ side.
So, this is also 35.
So this entire angle
right here is 70.
35 plus 35.
I should have drawn
this a lot bigger.
So, this right here
is 70 degrees.
And how do I figure it out?
I figure out this 35 because
this is an isosceles triangle.
And I figured out
that this is 35.
I figured out that this is right
here is 35 because it's
an opposite angle from a
transversal between two
parallel lines.
Because that line is parallel
to that line.
So, that was all
pretty useful.
Now, what if there was only
a way to figure out
what this angle was?
Because if we know this angle
and this angle, then we know
for sure this angle.
Well, I'm going to use
the same argument.
This line right here, this is
a radius of the triangle.
So this side right
here is also 9.
That side.
so, if we know that this side is
equal to this side-- let me
draw the triangle that I'm
talking about now, because I
think this is an important
problem.
So, I'm trying to figure
out the value of
this upside down triangle.
And I'll label it so you know
what I'm talking about.
So, this is P.
This is Q.
And this is the center
of the circle.
And we know that the side
is 9, this side is 9.
And we just figured out that
this angle right here is 70.
This was 35 plus another 35.
Once again, another isosceles
triangle.
If this side is equal to that
side, that this angle is equal
to this angle.
So, this angle also has
to be equal to 70.
And now, if we know
two angles of a
triangle, we know the third.
This has to be--
[PHONE RINGING]
I'm on a roll.
I'm not going to answer
the phone.
Oh I think it's my wife.
I'm going to call her back
right after this.
So what was I doing?
I lost my train of thought.
I was on a roll.
If this angle is 70 degrees,
this angle is 70 degrees, then
this angle has to be what?
70 plus 70 plus x is equal
to 180 degrees.
140 plus x is equal
to 40 degrees.
Sorry, is equal to 180.
My brain was skipping ahead.
x is equal to 40 degrees.
OK.
So that angle is 40 degrees
which is the same thing as
that angle.
So the length of-- so let's
go back to the problem.
We have to figure out what
this arc length is.
So, this angle, which is 40 over
all the degrees in the
circle, over 360, is going to be
equal to this arc length--
let's just call it x-- over
the circumference
of the whole circle.
And we know that the
circumference of the full
circle is 18 pi.
Let's see if we can
simplify this.
40 goes into 360-- that's 1/9.
So to this becomes 1 over 9.
Then we could cross multiply and
get 9x is equal to 18 pi.
x is equal to, 18 pi divided
by 9, is equal to 2 pi.
And, luckily, that's
one of the choices.
It's choice A.
See you in the next video.
I now have to call my wife.